-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
Let's get to the news.
Following reports
that Joint Chiefs of Staff
Chairman General Mark Milley
took steps to limit
former President Trump's ability
to order military actions,
White House press secretary
Jen Psaki defended Milley
and said, "It's important to
consider some of the context."
Okay, let's do that.
-♪ Bing, bing, bong, bong,
bing, bing, bing ♪
-He did the right thing.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden met virtually
yesterday
with British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson
and Australian Prime Minister
Scott Morrison
and, of course,
Morrison's translator.
"Oy, mate, how ya goin'?"
He says,
"It's nice to meet you."
Ahead of the Justice for J6
rally on Saturday
in support of
the Capitol rioters,
Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham told reporters,
"If anybody gets out of line,
they need to whack them."
That's pretty tough talk
for someone
who definitely calls the police
on spiders.
"I flushed them,
but he's crawling back up.
Hurry!"
[ Laughter ]
After she tweeted this week
that she has not received
the coronavirus vaccine
and had heard of a man
who became impotent from it,
rapper Nicki Minaj
said yesterday that she had been
invited to the White House.
This escalated
to the White House?
Nicki, did you ever think
maybe this guy
doesn't want his balls
to be trending so much?
"Hey, man, did you ever
text your cousin
and ask her to stop talking
about my nuts?"
"I did, but her phone was off
'cause she's meeting
with the president about them."
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Anthony Fauci said
in a new interview
that there's
no scientific evidence
to support rapper
Nicki Minaj's claim
that a friend of her cousin
is impotent
after his testicles
became swollen
from receiving
the coronavirus vaccine.
And going forward, Dr. Fauci
encourages all Americans
to take pause
when someone starts a story
with "a friend of my cousin."
House Democrats yesterday
proposed a tax hike
on tobacco and
nicotine products.
In related news,
Mary-Kate and Ashley
have breached the Capitol.
The National Toy Hall of Fame
has announced
that their 12 finalists
for the 2021 induction
include American Girl dolls,
the board game Battleship,
and sand.
I'm sorry, sand?
What kind of freak kid asks
their parents for sand?
Imagine Christmas being ruined
because the only thing
in your kid's PlayStation box
was a PlayStation.
"I specifically asked for sand!"
A British man was recently
arrested in the Netherlands
and brought to the Hague --
I'm sorry, sand?!
I guess I'm not ready
to move on.
You're inducting sand into
the National Toy Hall of Fame.
Was gravel not available?
[ Laughter ]
"Wow! So many people to thank.
First and foremost, erosion."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a burglar in Ohio
was arrested this week
after he allegedly
broke into a home,
ate chicken dinner leftovers,
swam in a pool,
lit a candle in the bathroom,
and then fell asleep
in a guest bedroom.
The man has been charged
with one count of
having a lovely evening.
That was the monologue,
everybody.